hallo YouTube chair slower simmer
friends this is grunge in here
welcome to the eleventh part of the
dirty chance tricks the modern
Scandinavian defense start with the more
order fo D far and after he captures D
file instead of routinely capturing the
deep ole black will play the move Knight
to f6 so idea is to capture with the
knight now it is very well known at the
highest level that if white wants to
maintain his advantage then he has to
play the move d4
if I place any other moves then not only
black will equalize very easily but that
can employ some of the nasty gambits
which white needs to be aware of it
for example if white plays the move c4
then there is an amazing Icelandic
gambit with start with the movie 6 and
after D captures a 6 and Bishop captures
c6 black is quite aggressively placed if
I place the move Knight to c3 then he
has to watch out for a gambit starting
with the move c6 and if I place the move
Knight to f3 then why it needs to deal
with surprising Portuguese gambit with
start with the move Bishop to g4
so all in all it is only black who is
having all the fun
after the Moody for the simple reason
which give Weiden advantages that when
black recaptured the pawn with denied
then white can play the Moosey for not
only grabbing the center in the space
but that means black has to move his
knight third time in the game now here
many books and videos have recommended
the move Knight to b6 and in fact that
is one of the main line but instead of
this in this lecture I am going to
propose a very interesting move that is
Knight to b4
if your opponent has seen this move
first time then his eyes will literally
lit up and he will think like hang on
isn't that a blunder contravene a piece
after the move Queen to e4 check and if
the Knightly through back then I can
always play the move defy and never
piece well that's true but the most
important point is that is exactly black
wants
now before we look at Queen to a4 there
is one point I like to mention is the
best move over here for the white is the
move a3 and after the move a3 yes why
definitely help slight edge in the game
but with the careful play like can
slowly equalize everything I am Bill
Pascal has done some wonderful analysis
on this move which you can find on the
chest lecture calm
apart from e3 if white plays other moves
then he needs to be very very careful
in a one quick game where my opponent
was more than 2000 plus rated he
robotically played the move Knight to c3
but to his horror he find out that after
one move Bishop to a5 and white is lost
so isn't that wonderful
okay let's see what exactly black is up
to after the move Queen to fo check well
here black will certainly play the moon
night eight on c6 so supporting his
brother and now white is obviously going
to play the move defy
no wonder here you open is going to
count how much rating he's getting after
this game but to his shock we are going
to play the amazing stunner that is the
MU B Phi BAM
why can pack his bag and go home B Phi
is that much little let's see here white
has four options and let's see each my
turn
the first more I want to consider is C
captures B Phi well after this black is
going to play the move Bishop to a5
which has a merit of creating a folk on
the C tube
if Y becomes greedy at this point and
take the c69
with either of the pawns for example d
capture c6 then the simply game is over
after the blacks next move that is
Bishop - C - BAM
so not only hitting the Queen but Queen
cannot move because there is a checkmate
trait on d1 which white needs to deal
with it first
none of the mood tries night 283 but
after this black can simply capture the
defy upon
gamba ting the whole piece let's see
what happens if white accept this peach
sacrifice so be cap to c6 here black
will continue with this Queen check and
now King has to move white cannot
casually play the move Bishop to e2 or
Bishop to e3 because let's say if you
place the move Bishop to e3
then after night - see - it is not only
for King in a rope but White Queen is a
goner
so that's not possible so King Devon is
forced after the MOOC into d1 black is
going to continue with the move rope to
DA check and after the only reply that
is Bishop to d2
it looks like black initiative is
running out of the fuel but I give you
few seconds can you find an amazing move
over here okay I hope you find this mu
that is rook captures d2 BAM
why doesn't have any good option except
he has to take this rook but after this
the very simple Queen check and white is
lost please note that King cannot go to
the sivan or the even square because of
the night check and in the next step
capturing the White Queen
so that means White has to forcefully go
to the e2 square but after this we are
going to play the move Queen captures B
to check and white King will not survive
longer
for example in one of my game my
opponent responded with the move King to
e3 here black can easily capture the
rook in the corner but instead of that I
played a stronger move that is e Phi so
now idea is to play the move Bishop to
c5 check my opponent was desperate to
save his rook so he played the move rook
to d1 but after Bishop to c5 check and
King to a3 Queen to f2 is actually a
checkmate
so if white is not careful enough then
game can be finished very very fast in
some lines
the second move I can try is the MU
Quinn captures v5 but after this black
and simply give this check with the Moon
Knight to see to [ __ ] king and rook
after the nature reply King to d1 black
has the amazing stunner that is Bishop
to d7 BAM there are three good
possibilities for the white or leads to
disaster
now the first move is if white foolishly
capture the knight on the C - then there
comes Knight to d4 and bye-bye miss
queen
if white is desperate enough to block
the B file with the move Bishop to d2
then after Knight to e5 attacking the
Queen and after Queen to b3 black and
simply capture the rook in the corner
and become a piece of
and it's hard and the most critical
question need to be asked what will
happen if white capture this night with
the pawn if be kept to c6
then if black wants black can have the
queen of the white for example the line
goes like this Bishop captures c6 with a
discovered check and after King captures
c2 Bishop captures Queen and pawn
captures Bishop white give up Queen for
three pieces which might be okay for
black but instead of all this there is a
stronger line which will completely
finish your opponent let's start with
the move Bishop to g4 BAM double check
few moves are very much forced so here
King has to capture this Knight
afterwards we give this check with the
Queen so again King is forced to move to
the c3 square and now we are going to
capture this bishop for the check
now please note if King goes on the D
file then Luke can come to the D file
and that will leads to the disaster for
white and accordingly if King goes to
the b3 then after Bishop to d1 white
King will be checkmated in few moves so
the best move over here is King to be
four afterwards we are going to capture
the b2 pawn with a check and after King
to a far we are going to capture the
rook in the corner after the whole
fireworks not only black emerged with an
exchanger but an attack to boot the next
threat of the black is to capture the a
to pole and finish the white off
I reached this position in one of my
game my opponent responded over here
with the move a3 so stopping any Queen
checks I responded with the MU a6
attacking the Queen and the obvious
response is Queen to be seven counter
attacking to my rook well in fact my
opponent never touched that rook
I played the move Queen to e5 check and
after King to before I played the movie
six I think at this point my opponent
was really fed up with his position so
he played the disaster move that is King
to a4 and he soon realized that
something went wrong after the move
Bishop to be even which forced the
resignation immediately
that hard move I can try is the move
Queen to b3 but after this the simplest
more on the world is night to d4
attacking the Queen and please note
Queen cannot capture the piece because
of the night to see to when white will
simply lose a queen so Queen has to move
to somewhere the best move suggested is
Queen to d1 but after this the simplest
is night to see to check and after King
moves to the only square that is d2 we
are going to capture the rook in the
corner so not only black emerged with a
piece of but white King is clearly
misplaced
last but not least the most critical
move is Queen to d1 here black will
continue with the move Bishop to a5 so
threatening once again a fork on the C 2
square so accordingly white needs to
defender square the only good reply is
Knight to e3
afterwards we are going to play another
aggressive move that is Knight to e5 so
not only saving a piece but now three
pcs are eyeing at juicy d3 square which
I don't think so
white can define
the best response over here is Knight to
f3 but after night check Bishop captures
and Knight captures white King has to
forcefully goes to the f1 square so it's
already a condition where white King has
been clearly misplaced after the MU King
to a fern I recommend that blacks should
capture the c-4 pole if white
immediately kept to the c4 pawn
then after Queen to defy normally black
is attacking the knight but black
position is quite cooked so instead of
this white has to play a better mood
than that that is Queen to a4 check here
black will play the move Queen to b7 and
offered a queen trade which white has to
accept if I decline this Queen trade and
capture the c4 pawn black can play the
Mook to d8 and grabbing the d5 on but
emerge with a better position so Quinn
trade is almost forced and now white is
going to regain his pawn with the move
Knight to c4 for a moment it looks like
white is doing fine
although is king is misplaced but Queen
has been exchanged so why doesn't have
any problems but see yourself here black
will continue with the move Bishop to b5
attacking the knight if Knight to a3
then Bishop to a6 and the threat remain
as it is
so the force reply left is b3 afterwards
we are going to castle on the Queen side
with attacking the d5 pawn which cannot
be defended
the best is king 2e2 but after a night
captures Bishop and rook captures Knight
and rook captures defy the dust is
settled down and not only black emerged
with a clear pawn up advantage but black
has a bishop pair to boot and it is only
black who is playing for the win in this
sort of situation
okay so with this we are concluding this
wonderful chapter I hope you like this
wonderful tricks exist in the modern
Scandinavian gambit feel free to like
subscribe and comment on this video
I'll meet you in another episode of
dirty chess tricks
bye